medical bills are a major frustration
for many Americans who wonder what
explains the prices and why they end up
paying so much starting Monday we're
investigating the lack of transparency
in health care pricing along with our
reporting partner clear health costs our
three-part series is called medical
price roulette consumer investigative
correspondent Anna Werner is digging
into why costs charged by hospitals and
other providers often vary dramatically
even within the same city we'll show you
the results of a pricing survey hear
from patients facing tens of thousands
of dollars in surprise bills and doctors
most of our viewers I think it'd be fair
to say don't understand the bills that
they get don't understand why the price
was so high is their transparency in
health care pricing oh my god no I mean
I'm laughing in the sense that you think
that that that patients are the only
ones that think there's no transparency
I mean people working in the system
don't often know what the price is when
my patients ask me what the price is I
don't have an answer for them nothing
about the United States health care
system really makes sense our three-part
series medical price roulette will try
to help you make sense of the system and
find ways to avoid being surprised by
medical bills in the future those
reports start Monday right here on CBS
this morning and I'm looking for I am
looking forward we're all gonna learn
something gallon